father and son did you get on each
other's nerves you better believe it
yeah I wouldn't get cemented it's me
before we started doing this you're sure
I learnt more about Jack than I ever did
when it was leave it at home yeah cuz
you read this that's an intense
experience being a co he's always
texting while he's bloodied Riley are
you driving a car oh uh that's no
language to use around your son okay
now Jack what is Aussie do that gets on
your nerves I mean breathe No okay so
there's road trip rules right yeah
everyone knows this if you fought in the
car roll the window down he does not do
that women you would let him navigate I
would I would like him to yeah are you a
good navigator Ozzie I'm so close you
dyslexic so you can't read a map
yeah Terry what about these days you
have all these apps I'm useless
oh you don't use you don't use apps you
don't use ways your trouble sending the
wrong message to the wrong buzz no no
these apps you're not sending anyone a
message no there's a burst of the voice
just says take a right take a left if
you put in the advance co-worker booting
to do watch the movie once you ones like
accidentally sent like Robert Plant a
text message being like I can't find the
cat
I love Robert Plant in concert singing a
Led Zeppelin tune getting at extra mazi
buy more of hate somebody
you said it back when you can't find the
guy you can't
you